[Música]
en la era digital qué tal que no solo
nos dedicáramos
para enseñar
cuantos de los que estamos aquí en algún
momento usamos un teléfono de monedas
cuántos enviamos un correo físico o
postal
y cuantos tenemos un celular conectado a
redes sociales y de hecho en este
momento podría llegar una notificación o
un mensaje
cuánto han cambiado las cosas y la vida
del ser humano las nuevas tecnologías
esta imagen tomada hace 13 años
y después de ocho años en el mismo lugar
revela como la tecnología ha cambiado
profundamente
humanidad
de hecho
cinco años después hoy de tener el
dispositivo enfrente para grabar nos
giramos
para hacer los protagonistas del
registro y eso no es un tema de self y
es un tema de cómo realmente la
tecnología está transformando la vida
del ser humano
la está transformando enormemente no se
trata solo de herramientas se trata de
escenarios de interacción de espacios de
convivencia
la web es el mejor ejemplo de ello la
primera versión de la web la web 1.0 una
cantidad de páginas web enlazadas en una
relación unidireccional
la web le informa al usuario algo
estático
a principios de este siglo esa web
evoluciona a la web 2.0 y se convierte
en un escenario de colaboración entonces
está llena de foros wikis blogs y redes
sociales
y coge la esfera de lo público y la
extiende a un escenario de lo virtual
donde la gente colabora comparte
construye y convive un escenario de
interacción social y lo que conocemos
actualmente la tercera acción de la web
como la web 3.0 ahí
y la inteligencia artificial los más
dispositivos móviles aplicaciones y lo
que llamamos la famosa nube
tratan de entender el lenguaje del ser
humano
entonces youtube te arroja resultados de
acuerdo a lo que estabas buscando antes
o weiss y google maps day siempre hay un
trancón esta vía es más rápida y estamos
casi entrando a la cuarta versión de la
web
la web 4.0
donde se desarrollan redes neuronales
artificiales donde las máquinas pueden
hablar entre ellas pero también donde se
incluye el internet de las cosas y
empezamos a ver cómo las máquinas se
relacionan con una estufa con una nevera
con un vehículo con un reloj con una
camiseta
estamos pasando de una web meramente
informativa y colaborativa a una que nos
ofrece soluciones y esto es una
verdadera revolución
y la
la
era digital'
es aquella en la que estamos
completamente inmersos todos hoy la gran
pregunta es
y qué tiene que ver la escuela con todo
eso
la escuela forma para la vida para la
vida y para la sociedad de hoy la
escuela forma para la ciudadanía y
formar en ciudadanía implica reconocer
todas estas transformaciones y darles
lugar en el contexto escolar si la
escuela no reconoce lo que está pasando
con la sociedad está perfectamente
preparada para el mundo que ya no existe
eso es lo que hace la escuela y la
escuela de hoy debe movilizarse debe
transformarse ya no son las cuatro
paredes que todos conocimos se extiende
a un escenario de la virtualidad
donde niños niños y adolescentes se
sienten como en casa porque cuando
nacieron así era el mundo ese es su
contexto natural entonces el contexto
escolar tiene el gran desafío de
reinventarse
de resignificar se me llama mucho la
atención que en muchas partes del mundo
la discusión hoy es prohibir los
celulares en las escuelas
cuando a través de este recurso
didáctico tengo una cámara
para grabar vídeo tomar fotografías un
gps una calculadora una grabadora de
vídeo y un sinnúmero de aplicaciones
para el aprendizaje del conocimiento
no se trata de desconocer los riesgos y
los peligros de la tecnología por
supuesto que no debemos considerarlos
pero no estoy viendo
no cuidamos a los niños del tráfico en
las calles prohibiéndoles que salgan de
la casa se trata de formar se trata de
dosificar fijar límite
y
con toda esta revolución tecnológica a
nosotros hoy nos vemos en una tarea
importante y es desarrollar las
competencias de las habilidades y las
actitudes para poder enfrentar el mundo
de hoy
la gran pregunta si la sociedad se ha
transformado en los cambios a
divertirnos y la escuela por supuesto se
está movilizando la pregunta del millón
es
cuál es el lugar del maestro porque el
maestro que está frente a la clase que
solamente transmite hechos datos
información el maestro que está todo el
tiempo frente al pizarrón y que
solamente
dicta la clase
puede y seguramente va a ser sustituido
por una pantalla y un vídeo
cuántos hemos aprendido cosas a través
de las nuevas tecnologías hacer el 9 una
corbata
hacer una lasaña aprender otro idioma la
información está a un clic pero la
información no el conocimiento
no el conocimiento y el maestro de hoy
no debe tener todo el conocimiento
imagínense un maestro que conoce todo el
ecosistema digital que sabe manejar
todas las herramientas
seguramente habrá momentos en que los
estudiantes saben más de algunas
situaciones y conceptos
que las que el maestro
probablemente un estudiantes además de
cómo usar snap chat o cómo jugar for
night o configurar un smartphone del uso
mecánico de las de las cosas
entonces qué hacemos sacamos al maestro
de la ecuación
la idea educativa es formar y enseñar
las matemáticas las ciencias del
lenguaje la robótica y la computación o
es más potente
pues el maestro de hoy tiene un lugar
privilegiado y exageradamente potente
el maestro de hoy es un mediador
un facilitador un articulador de todos
estos conocimientos
quien tiene el conocimiento pedagógico
para ayudarle al estudiante a que pueda
significar y encontrarle sentido al uso
tecnológico y en general a lo que hace
en la vida
el maestro
no es quien deposita en una vasija
información y transfiere y transmite
conocimiento
la tarea del maestro hoy es la tarea de
encender una llama
de entregar a las nuevas generaciones un
legado un testigo que corresponde pasar
de prepararlos para un mundo que se está
transformando increíblemente y a una
velocidad muy rápida
de ayudarles especialmente a desarrollar
la sensibilidad por el otro porque eso
no se resuelve en una plataforma ni
viendo vídeos de youtube
el maestro hoy por eso digo que tiene un
lugar muy privilegiado y potente como
agente de la educación para formar a las
nuevas generaciones hacia la
incertidumbre no sabemos en 10 años en
que vamos a estar
pero es muy difícil formar para la
incertidumbre si uno no sabe pues qué va
a pasar en 10 20 años
entonces en lugar de enseñar cosas vamos
a desarrollar capacidades como aprender
a aprender
se trata de entregarle tecnología al
estudiante para que resuelva problemas
para que cree para que se exprese y
haciendo cosas aprenda
de eso se trata
entonces toda esta revolución
tecnológica lo que nos está obligando es
a replantear los modelos educativos
al maestro como investigador y como
un aprendiz permanente quien debe
transitar la experiencia del aprendizaje
todo el tiempo
y quien debe cambiar el paradigma de
cómo se enseña
todo lo que les acabo de mencionar lo
que plantea es que debemos estamos en la
responsabilidad de los maestros e
incluidos los padres como primeros
formadores de replantear el paradigma de
cómo se empeña obviamente de fortalecer
las concepciones que sustentan el acto
educativo para que el planeo para que
evalúe una pregunta tan importante qué
sentido tiene la evaluación
que quiero construir con mis estudiantes
con mis estudiantes y adónde quiere
pegar
en todo caso el profesor tiene la
responsabilidad de reconocer el contexto
digital de desarrollar las competencias
digitales
pero también tiene la responsabilidad de
aprender de los estudiantes y con los
estudiantes
esto está explotando las variables
cartesianas tradicionales de la
educación
es cuestión de abrirse de tener apertura
al aprendizaje de explorar y
especialmente de reconocer quiénes son
los estudiantes hoy cuáles son sus
gustos cuáles son sus intereses qué es
lo que los mueve para lograr que los
aprendizajes sean significativos y lo
que les estoy diciendo es que las nuevas
tecnologías están convocando a maestros
ya estudiantes a encontrarse y transitar
juntos la experiencia del aprendizaje
entonces
la sociedad se ha revolucionado y se ha
transformado increíblemente los
contextos escolares también los
universitarios van un poco más rápido
la escuela apenas estaba discutiendo
celulares y ya la tecnología ponible
anda por todos los colegios
el lugar del maestro también se ha
resituado entonces pasamos de centros de
enseñanza del siglo 20 a centros de
aprendizaje del siglo 21
es por eso que al principio les decía en
la era digital' que tal que sólo nos
dedicáramos a enseñar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]